Найважливіші нововведення
пенсійної реформи, які незабаром відчують українці,
- прив'язка пенсії не до віку,
а до страхового стажу,
щорічна індексація,
підвищення мінімальної пенсії.
Мінімальну пенсію уряд збільшив
на сто сорок гривень,
до 1452 гривень.
Нині  "мінімалку" отримують
вісім мільйонів пенсіонерів.
Окрім цього, закон передбачає відновлення
виплат пенсій у повному розмірі для пенсіонерів,
які працюють. Раніше вони отримували
на 15% менші пенсії.
З 2019 року запрацює механізм індексації пенсій.
Тобто щороку пенсії автоматично підвищуватимуть
залежно від  інфляції та середньої зарплати.
Де-юре те, чого найбільше боялись українці,
не станеться. Закон не передбачає підвищення
пенсійного віку до 65 років, але, де-факто,
починаючи з наступного року,
збільшується мінімальний страховий стаж
для виходу на пенсію - з 15 до 25 років.
Тобто щоб піти на трудовий спокій у 60 років,
потрібно буде мати 25 років страхового стажу.
Якщо стаж менше 15 років, то у 65 років.
А до 2028 року мінімальний страховий стаж
зросте до 35 років.
Якщо страхового стажу взагалі немає, то людина
може претендувати на соціальну допомогу
від держави. А якщо стажу недостатньо,
то можна його придбати, однак
не більше п'яти років. Один рік стажу коштує
близько 17 тисяч гривень. А п'ять років –
більше 85 тисяч гривень.
Практично ви платите державі за місяць стажу
одну мінімальну пенсію.
Закон також скасовує
спеціальні пенсійні режими
для державних службовців, учених,
посадових осіб органів місцевого самоврядування,
прокурорів, депутатів і пенсії за вислугою років.
Пільговий вихід на пенсію буде можливий
лише для людей, які працюють у шкідливих
та важких умовах;
людей із особливими потребами;
матерів, які виховали п’ятьох дітей;
інвалідів із дитинства;
військових - учасників бойових дій.